I had been attracting a lot of beta
>> Dude, this guy is so filtered. Um that actually looks
ugly in fact. No, it doesn't look good. It actually looks ugly.
We hate the Ridge. You on that Stephen A. Smith salary Poki.
What do you mean we? What you talking about we?
I got linked to Pokimane video. Think before you sleep, just
being a misogynist. That would be funny. That could be cool.
Yeah, I'm down for that. Let's do that. Think before you sleep.
Viciously attacking.
You guys remember Think Before You Sleep? Infamous
Here's why I'm not married yet. I simply didn't feel as ever
the right time or opportunity to get married in my early to mid
20s. It's kind of nice to see that people aren't rushing into
marriage like they used to. Uh 29 if you're wondering. I thought
we would just start off with that considering that her advice
is to wait until you're 30 to consider marriage. >> As
a career-oriented
woman, want to settle for someone who's insecure about what I
do or wants to control me. Now, this clip does require a little
bit of nuance. For those of you who don't know, this is a famous
African-American female streamer named Pokimane. And if that
wasn't enough of a cue as Uh African-Canadian technically. Uh
just to be clear, African-Canadian.
why a partner of hers might be controlling, then look no further
than her Instagram page where she is constantly posting parasocial
girlfriend bait to get followers. So, I can imagine why a significant
other of hers would have a problem with that. But welcome to
modern Twitch where the worst people you know are finally getting
old. QT Cinderella is clocking in at 31. Then we Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait,
can we look at this guy's wife,
Him and Britney Venti, I think were they engaged only or did
they actually get married? Cuz I need to go and check out we're
going to have to scope out Britney Venti's Instagram, okay? Is
Britney Venti posting zero things like this cuz I could have
sworn Britney Venti likes the fact that she thinks she's she's
attractive and she posts selfies and she Am I out of my mind?
This guy's ex-wife?
Ex-fiancé, whatever the have Valkyrae at 34. I feel mentally
stunted. Like I don't feel 34. I'm a middle-aged woman. Hasan
better wife her up. And finally, as I said, we have Iman who
is about to turn 30. I've always been someone who wanted kids,
wanted to start a family. He better hurry. Guys get like an extra
10 years to act like they're still in high school despite being
well into adulthood. But because of biological limitations, once
women hit maybe 20 Wait, we're just going to run back. We're
just going to run back the Molly meme egg timer stuff. Let's
22. They got to get moving before their time runs out. >> of
that, there's such a pres Here's here's the just the facts, okay?
Um unless it is through pure discipline
in building out like a big like business empire or something
that you didn't have, you know, kids or like let's say How should
I put this? If you've avoided having kids for a very long time
because you don't like kids and they would be like too big an
inconvenience, it's it's totally fine not to have kids. But like
if you think adding them late in your life is good, man, I think
if you want a family, you should start a family early. I think
you get used to living life without kids and a lot of those people
I've witnessed who wait a long time end up not being very good
parents.
It's not that it's impossible. It's totally possible. It's totally
possible Pokimane has has kids and she's a great parent. It's
not impossible. I'm just saying that for a lot of people, a lot
of people don't have kids cuz they kind of don't want kids. They
like taking care of themselves. They like being like kind of
selfish. If you are selfish,
you should probably think about not having kids. What about you
then? I'm selfish. She's exactly why I came to this determination
myself. I am a selfish person. I don't want to have kids because
I don't think I would be a good parent.
I'm a selfish person.
That's how it is. If you're a single guy who wants to have kids
like right now, should you No. No. No, never. I've got a message
for you. Stop Sir. This show is good. I like the first season
of this pressure on women. I feel like we're constantly told
and conditioned to think that our greatest value is bringing
life into this world, which I find painfully
>> Clearly, she took her general education courses in college
seriously. So, now we have more of an Like it has nothing to
do with biology. Realistically, biology doesn't even matter because
you can adopt kids. You could be a parent. It's just like if
you held off being a a parent because it wasn't important to
you at all, you don't really care about having kids, and then
one day you just feel your your like getting older and you're
like, well, this would be a nice addition. Get a dog. Okay? Get
a dog, man.
That's that's all you should do. Just get a dog.
Do not do not force
kids into your life when you have never really wanted them. It's
it just never works out for the kids,
Trying to end the human race? No, I think it you should find
a way for humanity to have kids when they're younger. Like for
people to have kids when they're younger. I know people who are
parents who got into being who basically graduated university,
got their first jobs, immediately started having kids. They're
all wonderful parents. Every single one of those people, wonderful
parents who are super motivated to take care of those kids. That's
the way it should be.
If you want to have parent if you want to have kids like way
later, I it just tends not to work. Like I see it not working
in my experience, okay? >> insight on why she's in this
>> Perfection and power are overrated.
I think you are very wise Oh, I should say though, I should say,
if how should I say this? It's only if it's the selfishness thing.
Like I feel like I'm enlightened. I feel like I can see that
I I don't want kids, I shouldn't have kids. Like that's not something
I prioritize cuz I'm selfish. If you Like let's say you just
had circumstances, right? Let's say you
you know, you had two or three relationships you thought were
going the right way and they just ended up not working out at
the last moment. Yeah, you're the perfect person that can have
kids when when it's later, right? For
Sorry, I don't mean to like I'm not saying this is an age thing.
I'm saying I get the feeling that Pokimane has done this cuz
she really likes indulging like in in intention and herself in
a very honest in a very obvious way. There's no age cut off.
Why would there be an age cut off? I mean, probably if you're
going to be like daughtering, if you're going to be in your like
dotage by the time your kid's like 10, like probably don't have
kids when you're like 60 or
Probably less reasonable.
Right? As a guy,
um as a woman, I mean, as late as you can. Get your eggs frozen,
I guess, if you want to have them way later.
I used to choose happiness and love. Uncle Iroh advice videos
are looking pretty based these days when it comes to the behavior
of Twitch streamers. So, as for people like Iman who are following
the golden path in their careers or people who are wasting like
a decade doing nothing in their parents' basement, let me just
say that these traditional milestones have been created for a
reason. And the reason older people are pressuring you and saying
that time is running out is because they know that you only have
a finite amount of time to achieve certain things before you're
locked out of them. And they know that life constantly gets harder
and harder as you get older. But when people ignore traditional
wisdom and they start running up against the time limit for achieving
major life milestones, they'll start coping like this. >> I
bought an engagement ring.
I Oh.
The getting married thing is not a difficult thing to do.
Getting married just requires low impulse control, okay? You
Pokimane could totally be married right now. 100%. Pokimane doesn't
even have to work anymore. She is set for life.
This is This is where I don't like this cope is like, oh, Pokimane's
the example. No, she's not. Of this of the person who's like
forever alone and and coping, no, she's not. This is rage bait
for low IQ like you. So, you freak out and make videos about
it. You are being filtered hard. In fact, do not have kids, Think
Before You Sleep. You have been filtered. You will contribute
nothing of meaning to this world. You have no value. Stop. Do
not Do not have kids. Absolutely do not. >> For myself.
Okay, but you guys told me to. The person that you are engaged
to the most in your entire lifetime is your damn self. So, why
shouldn't I get this ring for my [snorts] damn self? That was
Pokimane showing off her African-American roots. I'm surprised
Beyoncé didn't start playing in the background. But also, what
a callback to Emma Watson announcing that she was self-partnered
when she was about to turn 30. I never believed the whole I'm
happy single
spiel. But I'm very
happy. I call it being self-partnered. What an internet classic.
I'm glad to see that Pokimane is paying tribute by doing her
own iteration of it for modern >> This is me
proposing to myself. Look at the gorgeous diamonds. You know
when jewelry is so pretty, you want to eat it? Is that just me?
Like it's so delectable.
Am I the only person who thinks this ring looks ugly? It looks
like that snake that Dude, this guy is so filtered. This guy
is so ugly.
That actually looks ugly in fact. No, it doesn't look good. It
actually looks ugly. It actually is pretty terrible.
>> I don't know if that's some sort of metaphor or if it's
the kind of jewelry that an evil stepmother from a Disney movie
would wear. But I guess it's good that she likes it. >> Will
I be with me for the rest of my life? Well, yes, I've no choice.
I'm going to have the opportunity to gift my husband the sickest
engagement ring for men that there ever was and I cannot wait.
You guys know how much I love gift-giving and just that idea
makes me so happy. I can think of nothing more emasculating than
a woman proposing to a man. I'll never understand these women's
impulse for turning their boyfriends into men that they will
hate. About a year or two ago, like a year and a half, something
like that, I realized
I had been attracting a lot of beta
Dude, that's [__] up. You know, I was like, I'm trying
to cop a dude. Bro, did she just laugh at beta males? What? What?
Who does she think pays her bills? That's rude, man. I realized
I had been attracting a lot of beta
You Dude, that is crazy.
That's some crazy giggling, bro. >> I'm trying to cop a
dude. All I got are
You don't understand. And I was like,
>> That's funny. I'm sorry, that's really
That's incredibly funny to me.
Maybe it's because you're looking for a guy who would let you
propose to him. It's funny watching a person whose entire life
history is filmed because you can see her preaching the modern
values, followed by getting into various dramas because she's
not actually attracted to the relationships that she claims are
ideal. I don't know if this is controversial, but I'm in New
York right now, and I've noticed that the hottest men, sorry,
the most attractive
all happen to be gay.
More evidence that if you just Okay, that's just facts. I'm sorry.
Gay men That's a stereotype that's 100% true.
Gay men care about grooming. That's just real. That's just a
thing that is true
We all know that.
Bro, all Look no further than the Austin show. Raj, okay? Raj
Patel.
That guy That guy is like 35 and at like 8% body fat. That guy
is crazy. Let's follow the traditional rules, you wouldn't have
That guy is like, by the way, I guarantee you Austin show, the
reason he doesn't stream or anything, I dude, I'm going to say
some crazy [__] That guy is definitely like
a sugar baby for like the richest gay tech billionaires in Silicon
Valley, 100%.
That guy is getting like fat stacks for going to Peter Thiel
parties. I know it for a fact, obviously, obviously true.
Brain says no. Varina's coping. Varina's
Brain's crazy coping right now. Uh Clavicular is going that route
as well. He's going to be getting like a sugar daddy for sure.
He's a boyfriend? Oh, yeah. I'm I'm sure that
He has a boyfriend? Oh my god. Did you know that a lot of those
gay executives are literally married and still go to
Dude, what? Huh? However, I think these videos are a sign of
a new phase of content creation for Imane or a new creative outlet.
>> While I owe my career to streaming, it was also the
source of a lot of difficult moments and harassment that I don't
experience on other platforms, and I can confirm it's been really
healing to explore other creative outlets. Now, a reasonable
person might say that being a pretend parasocial girlfriend to
tons of lonely men as you pirate old episodes of Avatar for your
stream is not very creative, but you know, this is Twitch we're
talking about here. I mean, technically, Amouranth is the most
well-put-together streamer when it comes to life milestones because
she's married. So, the standards aren't that high here, but it
seems like Imane is gra Sort of the poster child for why rushing
into a marriage might not be the best idea.
Financially, they're doing terrific.
Yeah, financially, they're doing terrific, okay? But realistically,
this guy just kind of gave away, well, at least she's married.
Bro, I don't know about I Are we doing at least she's married?
graduating to a new era in her career. She started out with her
League of Legends and phase. If she wanted to speak like that,
she should have picked Heroes of Newerth. Then she had her phase
where she went after people's sponsors. And I will say for this
company to sponsor a video that's literally 20 minutes of talking
[__] about me? If I ever see you in my
on sight. On
After that, she had her entitled rich
Was that really that bad?
That's not going after sponsors. That's saying, I'm I'm not going
to work with you. That's her right. She's not saying, don't sponsor
this guy. She's saying, you sponsored this guy? You.
I'll never work with you. I don't know if the I don't know if
that rises to going after sponsors if she just says it in public.
And also,
let's be real, that's probably not even true. That's Is she going
to Is she going to turn down free money?
She going to turn down free money? girl phase. A lot of people
were offended by this tweet, but personally, I'm glad that she
was being her true self here. Like, if you're a broke boy, just
say so. Personally, I enjoy it when catty Pokimane stupidly calls
her followers broke beta males. However, now I think that we're
entering my favorite era of Pokimane, which is her Eat, Pray,
Love phase. This year, I fully cut someone out of my life who
used to be a close friend, but was lying to me, lying about me,
and generally causing me so much emotional turmoil that I needed
a lot of therapy, but after I cut them off, I did not message
them once. You go, Poki. Good for you for not messaging him.
You earned that candle. Also, for the guys who haven't been forced
to watch Eat, Pray, Love, it is quite possibly the most woman
movie that's ever been created. Eat, I've never seen Eat, Pray,
Love. >> is about a 40-year-old New York career girly with
no children who goes off to Italy and gets fat and then becomes
wise by learning from India after Brother, Jennifer Roberts got
fat?
Is she capable?
Does she even have a stomach or has that [__] been
surgically removed?
She divorces her husband who is deeply in love with her because
he's short, I'm guessing, or because she got married too young,
which is what she said in the movie. Of course, they have to
make sure they poison young women into thinking that being like
28 is too young to make a commitment. I mean, undatable men have
their manic pixie dream girl movies, and undatable women have
Eat, Pray, Love and Morning Glory Milking Farm for when the life
advice
>> Are these related? Eat, Pray, Love? Are Eat, Pray, Love
girls the same as Morning Glory Milking Farm girls?
I feel like no, but >> turns them into a spinster. ridding
myself of a lot of my people-pleasing tendencies, and I'm so
proud of myself for that. I am wishing you a happy New Year,
and I'm rooting for us. Is that a real book? That's 100% a real
book. Well, I'm glad that you're figuring out [__]
that you should have learned when you're like 21.
Uh that wish isn't coming true, by the way. She didn't get all
the candles? That wish will not come true
at all. >> You always talk in bumper sticker. Pokimane
has definitely seen this movie. She constantly speaks in platitudes
that should be on Hallmark cards. By the way, just as a little
side note, the woman who wrote the book Eat, Pray, Love was
insane. On screen is a video about that. Let me just say that
it makes sense that the advice given in that movie is horrendous
feel-good that will actually harm your life if you follow it.
Now, as for the late bloomer part in learning teenager lessons
when you're almost middle-age, I guess that's fine. Better to
learn late than never, but the part that I have an issue with
is the part where she has to publicly congratulate herself because
it comes off as incredibly narcissistic.
And what I mean by that is that this Eat, Pray,
Pokimane has been the center of attention of thousands of people
for like since she was 20, since she was 18, 19, 20. Maybe before
that, I don't know when she started streaming, actually.
That level of attention for that period of time during your developmental
years breaks you as a human.
You become a narcissist not by your own choice, but automatically.
You just have people catering to your whims. It breaks people.
Almost certainly, she is those things.
But I don't know what What are we This is just This would be
good business decision This would be a good business decision
either way. All the people sitting about her make her so much
money. I love video is like when you go to a job interview and
they say, "Tell us about one of your flaws." And you're like
supposed to lie by taking a positive thing about you and frame
it as a negative. So, tell me about a weakness of yours. The
common tactic with this question is to write a strength, but
word it as a weakness. Like, Oh, I usually I'm such a perfectionist
with my work that I'll give up all of my spare time to make sure
my [__] gets done at the cost Why is he ruining this
guy's good name?
I forget who this guy is, but I I remember I watched his videos
a long time ago. of me own family come So, Imane saying that
one of her flaws is that she's such a people pleaser is like
her saying, "I'm sorry. You see, I'm missing a bunch of important
life milestones and behaving like I'm 16 because I am just too
much of a people pleaser. I'm just too much of a good person.
I give too much to everyone else at my own expense."
There's no way.
By the way, I just want to remind you that this is the same guy
who did a whole video sweeping for Techtone.
Techtone is far more of a narcissistic
than anybody you or him target, okay? He is the worst of the
worst when it comes to this behavior. It is not close.
How in the world Where does this guy get off? Um actually, actually,
Pokimane, this is like narcissistic behavior and important life
milestones and behaving like I'm 16 because I am just too much
of a people pleaser. I'm just too much of a good person. I give
too much to everyone else at Do you remember when NotSoErudite
asked Techtone, "What Where have you made a mistake?
Um where have you made a mistake in like some of your personal
relationships?" And he goes, "My mistakes, man, have just been
trusting people too much. I trust people too much and then they
they come after me and and Oh, yeah, I've never But other than
that, no, I never make mistakes, dude. There is no
How in the world I don't I don't get it. I actually don't. If
he was going to apply this lens equally, he just he obviously
just doesn't like Pokimane.
He likes Teck N9ne, he doesn't like
That tells us a little bit at least, okay? A little bit. I don't
want to go out of my way to just call him a misogynist, even
though he clearly is. He's a MGTOW, total MGTOW, but like I If
you hate this behavior, your defense of Teck N9ne makes no sense.
>> my own expense. Pokimane makes videos like this a lot.
However, for everyone else is a late bloomer and not a narcissist,
there's a bit of ancient wisdom that's been circling around the
internet that people are calling maxing. People have figured
out that all of the overthinking and introspection is not actually
helping them become happy. And that's because most people let
their own heads get in the way, which prevents them from achieving
their goals. And so the internet has realized that it's actually
better to act as if you're stupid, like Forrest Gump. >> He's
not bound by adult worries. Someone offers an opportunity, he
takes it. No self-doubt, no overthinking, no paralysis, just
do it. And every single time, it works out. Why? Not because
he's lucky, because he's not standing in his own way. Also note
that a lot of these success that Forrest Gump experiences in
that movie is due to him listening to the advice of people who
are smarter THAN HIM. WHAT'S YOUR SOLE PURPOSE IN THIS ARMY?
TO DO WHATEVER you tell me, DRILL SERGEANT. GOD [screaming] DAMN
IT, GUMP. YOU'RE A GOD DAMN GENIUS. YOU CAN ACTUALLY LIVE A pretty
good life if you [laughter] just listen to the advice of old
people who are competent or have the lifestyle that you want.
Though, certainly, you don't want to end up attention-seeking
and cringe like this when you get older. I bought my first ever
Birkin, and although I'd love to own one someday, I first wanted
to buy one for a very special person in my life, my manager.
I couldn't think of a more deserving person to have such a coveted
bag.
Your manager literally struggles to pay his her bills and you're
going to get her like a $10,000 handbag when you could have just
given her that money and then maybe she would have been like
rent-free for a month and and that would have been better.
Do you [clears throat] even think about what your manager wanted?
You're just going to give this gift and it's like so >> Except
maybe you, which is why I got a second one. I love gifting you
guys because you've been just as kind and supportive of me as
my friends and my team has been. Right. Hopefully, someday, the
poor multi-time millionaire African-American streamer Pokimane
will be able to afford her own $20,000 Hermes Birkin bag. If
you're a Wait, was she implying implying that she couldn't buy
one? Was that the implication there?
Though, certainly, you don't want to end up attention-seeking
and cringe like this when you get older. I bought my first ever
Birkin, and although I'd love to own one someday, I first wanted
to buy one for a very special person in my life, my manager.
I couldn't think I don't Is anybody watching this
getting the impression Pokimane can't afford this? She's talking
about buying a $25,000 gift for somebody. I thought it was 10.
I think you can get Birkins for like 10.
But I like it seems pretty clear that you're watching this you
she could afford two. She makes a [__] ton of of
a more deserving person to have such a coveted bag. Except maybe
you, which is why I got a second one. I love gifting you guys
because you've been just as kind and supportive of me as my friends
and my team has been. Right. Hopefully, someday, the poor multi-
Oh, she probably did get them for free, though. Yeah, that's
true.
Just like Hasan, right, for rain? Hasan doesn't actually own
any expensive clothes. He just gets all of them gifted to him
for free. Totally. That's a totally reasonable thing to believe.
I will say that may be the only thing that explains his fashion
sense is getting different shirts, pants, hats from different
vendors and then mixing them together as best he can. That might
explain some of the fashion sense, but otherwise, I I can't believe
that, okay? African-American streamer Pokimane will be able to
afford her own $20,000 Hermes Birkin bag. If you're a broke boy,
just say so. I swear nothing will turn you into a misogynist
faster than learning Hermes's business plan and how effective
it is on women. It's basically a luxury gacha game store where
the loot boxes are $5,000
and when you pull ultra-rare items, you still have to pay for
them. But also imagine not being able to gift your manager something
without publicizing it. And Pokimane publicizes how generous
she is quite frequently. Honestly, these giveaways that she does
look a lot like she's bribing people to watch her or be her friend.
I don't get how she's like, "Maybe one day I can afford a Birkin
for myself." when she also releases videos openly bragging about
her gifting her friends purses that are in the city. How many
ti- How many times have looked up a Hasan jacket that I liked
just to see the 1.5k price
Every time. Is that more than one time? You get to pick your
Birkin in most cases. Weird. Oh, real- Wait.
You don't get to? He said it was like a gacha game. >> thousands
of dollars each. But probably the worst part of her showing her
audience how great it is to let life milestones pass by for the
sake of your career is that she does this whole girlfriend simulator
bit to make money despite not having to because she's insanely
rich. And the issue with that is that she can't really date anyone
because she'll lose a ton of her following, which is why she
has to make
Does this guy think Pokimane hasn't dated people multiple times
throughout her career?
I I got some news for you, man.
When influencers When influencer women tell you they're single,
they're very often lying to you. They They actually just lie.
They go on the internet and they tell lies. How could she possibly
hide a relationship when all she does is post TikToks like a
90-second TikTok once every 2 weeks? How could she hide a relationship?
I have no
was like this. I have to introduce you to a new current character
in my life. This is Chris, also known as my friend Chris, also
known as my neighbor. Imane, nobody believes that this guy is
in the video because he's your neighbor, unless he's gay or you
have really terrible boundaries. We met at one of those everybody
in the building gets together kind of parties. And then there
were board games for people in the building, so we got to know
each other at board game nights. Chris cooks a lot, moves a lot,
and he sings. Chris, sing.
I'm older than you, say Like, realistically,
I feel like with Pokimane with Pokimane specifically, okay? I
feel like there's a not insignificant chance that this dude is
from a casting agency in LA and she picked some dude to come
and pretend to be her boyfriend just so she could fake not have
a boyfriend. She She's faking not having a boyfriend, okay? Sorry,
she's faking have a boyfriend so she can fake not having a boyfriend
so that she can make people rage on the internet. I actually
believe that that's what's happening here. That she is double
tricking people. She's like doing a a double fake, okay? That
this is just some dude who's like literally a casting person.
I'm not even joking, man.
Damn, I'm pretty bored.
Okay, me, too. Right, your neighbor that you met at board game
nights who is close in age and comes over to cook for you because
we all know she can't. Your neighbor who goes to the gym with
you to lift while you go off and do a bunch of exercises that
are largely useless. She does [__] like this a lot,
so I imagine that she knows as much about working out as she
does cooking. Anyway, nobody [laughter] believed her story in
this Dude, Pokimane exercise rage bait would be so lit. Could
you imagine Pokimane doing like bad exercise advice? How just
that I feel like the overlap of MGTOWs and gym bros is pretty
high sometimes and that would make people seethe so
hard. It would be so
funny, man.
Oh my god, that would be awesome. I I just get to Dude, it's
like the most free content in the world. I watch this person
intentionally rage bait all the time. And then I just get to
watch people seethe.
$50 cookies? Oh, that cookie business went out of business. That
cookie business has been out of business for like a year and
a half now. Those cookies don't exist. >> simps became
depressed be- Turns out there were too many broke
Too many broke boys and they said so. >> Cuz now it's finally
over. Dude, Poki like I I can sing better. I can cook better.
I can do better. I can be better. I'm everything this guy can
be. Just message me back, please. That's right, Miss Kif. It
could have been you. Now, I'm not exactly sure why Imane has
picked this method of revealing her
Miss Kif and Miss Miss Kif and Pokimane are friends.
They're literally They're literally friends. I think I think
they're still friends. Maybe they're not. Maybe that's the person
she cut out of her life. I don't know. But they were literally
friends for a long time. Oh, was Was Imane one of the people
who unfollowed him? Remember when Miz was going through that
whole thing? Right? He was going through that whole thing with
he he was like going through his Twitter followers to see who
unfollowed
Remember that? She's rich enough to never have to work again.
So, if family was actually a priority, she would just take a
break from the internet. So, I don't know why That's true. That's
true, as well. That goes for her and Sneako. That's her and Sneako.
If Sneako was actually prioritizing family and wanted to like
take care of that stuff, he would be finding a family. He would
stop going to like crazy influencer parties. He'd stop having
meaningless He would go and start a family.
Your actions are your intentions.
Do not say you want to start a family and then never take a step
towards starting a family. Shut up. >> why she's doing
all this. However, I do know that e-girls always have stalkers
who are trying to expose every bit of her personal life. Maybe
one of them found out and was trying to expose it, so she's like,
"Okay, well, I'll just say he's a really good friend. That's
why we shot this gym video together." But even though this looks
suspicious as hell, she's still insistent on gaslighting people.
I posted a gym video with my neighbor. >> that. Was it
actually your neighbor? Yes. Okay, that's what I thought. >> we
met at um you know those building get-togethers where they're
like, "Everybody in this building, come hang out." kind of parties.
And then we got to know each other at board game nights for like
people in the building essentially, or like friends on the same
floor sort of thing. And then people on Twitter were like, "Imagine
having to hide your partner because your community's going to
freak out." And then my whole community is like, "Oh my god,
cute video." >> You know? I'm like, it just feels like
Okay. Two entirely different
>> Lily doesn't believe her one even one iota at all. Lily
Lily doesn't believe her at all. Dude, Lily's face when they
cut to Lily right here, she's like tells the story this whole
story with like her Pokimane voice and affectation, and [laughter]
Lily's just like, "Okay." You know? I'm like, it just feels like
Okay. I said I could just see it. Lily Lily's sitting here like,
"Yeah, yeah, okay. >> Two entirely different worlds. Again,
I'm not sure why she would Dude, I want to watch the rest of
that clip with Lily. I feel like Lily is going to call her out.
I feel like Lily is going to be like, "Uh-huh." Cuz here's the
thing, if you have somebody who you meet at an event like that
who isn't even in your sphere, who you get along with, who is
attractive,
who clearly like must make a decent amount of money to live in
the same building as Amouranth in the first
what what's the isn't that isn't that a match, man? Isn't that
a match?
Like, why why would you not be interested there? I I see I don't
get the reason that you're not interested.
Do you know what I'm saying?
would show this guy in a room alone with her if they were not
dating and if he's not gay. I guess the tier three subs who thinks
she will date them if they give her enough money are really socially
unaware, but then again, Miss Kifflin Amouranth dated for multiple
years and people didn't know, even though it's obvious they were
dating if you watch content with them together. But to further
make my point that Amouranth is lying to everyone, it's not just
the Instagram boyfriend-girlfriend videos that she has this guy
participate in, it's also this. Oh, and he sings a lot of songs
in China / in Chinese. Yep. Wait, I've never heard you sing in
Chinese. Really? Yeah. What?
Now that we've established that he can sing in Chinese, allow
me to show you this clip of her on a stream. Wait, so you what
did you think of China? Cuz you were you also went you went twice,
>> freaking love it. Yeah, but you got you got food poisoning
the first time.
>> This dude Okay, I'm starting to get it. This dude's
This dude's a honey dick, okay? This dude is a This guy's a CCP
agent, all right? Sent here to do CCP propaganda and spy on somebody
who is high up in the social structure in America, all right?
I see it. I see it.
I see it. >> I'm in a very Chinese phase of my life. Yeah.
[laughter] I'm like I I really really love it. What an incredibly
weird face to suddenly go through the minute you meet a Chinese
guy? I mean, she's certainly spreading those communist beliefs.
Do you think someday we'll have a revolution like that in America?
Might be. I don't know. Right? It's getting there, right? >> Right.
We've already had one. Another one. What's going on? Yeah, I
think it is. The wealth disparity is getting bad. Yeah. The wage
gap, I hate that [__] No wealth I've seen this clip
before. I forgot Jason did that. The wage gap, I hate that [__]
No, the wage gap's like men and women.
>> The wage gap, I hate that [__] Dude, that's
if I In my head I want to believe that Jason the Weens like incredibly
socially quick and he just like made that joke knowing it was
wrong, but I don't think that's likely. I want to believe it,
but I don't but I don't think it's likely. >> wealth disparity
Wage gap is like between men and women. Men and women, we love
each other. That's that's that. And we hate the rich. Anyways.
Too much.
Dude, that This clip made people see this so badly.
So badly.
We hate the rich. You on that Stephen A. Smith salary, Poki.
What do you mean we? What you talking about we?
Ayo. Ayo, what are you talking about we? What you talking about
we?
I hate the rich.
Is he in the video? No, he is in the video, yeah. No. Like the
ultra rich, the ultra giga rich. The unnecessary
>> They're going to clip that and then it's going to make
you look bad. Oh. You got to say you got to say the billionaires.
The billionaires, the Bezos. I don't know what it is with these
people who are walking around with like a minimum of eight figures
in their pocket who feel the need to pretend that they're poor.
More recently, Ludwig's girlfriend QTCinderella and the biggest
YouTuber MrBeast, who I'm now fully convinced is AI, were larping
as broke. >> You said you you keep less than $1 million
for yourself despite being a paper billionaire. Why do you choose
to operate that way? It's funny talking about my personal finances
cuz no one ever believes anything I say. So, I mean, they're
just like, "You're a billionaire." I'm like, that's net worth.
I don't I have negative money right now. I'm borrowing money.
That's how little money I have. Um technically everyone watching
this video has more money than me. Um Okay, but that's not true.
We're not talking about dude, why do you why do you feel like
that Unfortunately,
I feel like if I see you and you're a popular creator and you
tell me you have no money in your checking account, I know that
means you're wealthy.
I know that means you're wealthy. We're talking about wealth,
obviously.
Like wealth.
Do you know what Do you know I I don't have money. I have to
borrow money. Yeah, when you go to borrow money, does the bank
ask you, "Do you want a million dollars or 10 million or 100
million?" Like, is there a limit to what the banks tried to loan
you? No? If no, then you're rich. Stop larping. What the in their
bank account. >> I mean, you are a millionaire.
Okay, probably not 100, but a bank would definitely loan MrBeast
10, 50, maybe even 100 million dollars.
Dude, it's crazy to That was That was insane to me. That's like
infinitely worse than Poki. Saying that, that's like actually
lying on a fundamental level. Poki just doesn't see herself as
rich. This guy is going, "I actually
I actually just I'm like borrowing money. I barely got anything.
It's my personal finances."
What? Technically everyone watching this video has more money
>> are a millionaire. God damn it. I mean, you are a millionaire.
I love that you think [clears throat]
You're not a millionaire.
I could see QT I could see QTCinderella not having that much.
Like net worth, maybe net worth. Combined with Ludwig, I would
think so, but QT herself I feel like unless she's getting equity
on some of the things,
I Does she stream that much and make that much money? No chat
No chat she's not a millionaire net. Well, I think Here's the
thing is I'm sure she's attached equity-wise with some of Ludwig's
businesses, but she doesn't stream that much.
Right? QTCINDERELLA.
OH, HOLD ON. FEAR& probably posting a money. Yeah, never
Um net worth.
Do we get an estimate here? I could see her not having that much
cuz I don't think some of her businesses make a lot of money.
What is Fear&? It's the podcast.
Fear& Patreon alone is like 100k a month. Yeah, but then
that's split five ways, right? 300k a year from Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah, the Fear& stuff is pretty crazy. I do wonder
how she could possibly not have
a million dollar net worth. That would be pretty crazy.
That would be That would be a little weird. I do think so. Hold
on. Where am I? Here we are. Savings,
brokerage, all investments, all assets, you're not a millionaire.
No.
Like this seems like something where I What I think is happening
here is realistically her and Ludwig probably under most laws
have nearly like conjoint assets, right? I don't think they're
married, but I I'm guessing they have nearly conjoint assets
and it's like, "Well,
what does your like long-term partner
Right? What do you What do you guys have together?
Come on, be honest. Right? Like they'd have to be common law
married in California. You'd think so, right? And then from there
like Ludwig's I If Ludwig has less than a then like a seven-figure
net worth, I would be incredibly shocked. Ludwig's got to be
Ludwig's got to be easily into an eight-figure net worth net
worth, no matter what, right? >> too much. Oh Yeah, he's
got to be like more than I I I would guess closer to 20 million
than 10. Shut up. >> Even if you're not lying about your
income, your long-term boyfriend Ludwig is insanely rich. He's
so rich that he can lose millions of dollars on a failed business
and brag about it. >> I think your company got shut down
and you lost like how much? >> I lost more millions than
you'll ever
Holy [__] Broke Boy Hasan, another prominent eat
the rich fanatic, was just caught in Cuba wearing like $5,000
of clothes. And if that doesn't convince you that these people
are all insanely rich, then look no further than their luxury
beliefs. >> I traveled a lot to Paris and I noticed it's
because I just get along so well with the people there. In Paris,
there are a lot of Middle Eastern, North African, and Arab people,
my people. Yeah, I just love all the Nigerian migrant scammers
that have swarmed Paris with illegal markets. Gee, it must be
awesome as a rich person who can afford to live outside of Wait,
this Does this guy think Nigeria is North Africa?
Did Hold on. What did she say there? Listen again. and their
luxury beliefs. >> I traveled a lot to Paris and I noticed
it's because I just get along so well with the people there.
In Paris, there are a lot of Middle Eastern, North African, and
Arab people, my people.
None of those are Nigerian people. He just didn't listen. He
just doesn't know that North Africa is not Nigeria.
She's describing people of, you know, Phoenician descent, Arab
descent. Right? She's not talking about people from
I'm sorry, it like it does make a difference. That's not what
she described. And he's like, "Oh, well, Nigerian people are
ruining Paris." Shut up. Yeah, I just love all the Nigerian migrant
scammers that have swarmed Paris with illegal markets. Gee, it
must be awesome as a rich person who can afford to live outside
of poor crime-ridden communities to talk about how great mass
third world immigration is. I mean, Morocco is so great that
Pokimane's parents fled to Canada when she was young so she wouldn't
have to grow up As for the boyfriend stuff, I don't Wait, did
they flee or did they
I I don't know how bad Morocco is. I Morocco was like quite a
nice place for a long time.
Phoenicians exist. Well, Phoenicians don't really exist anymore.
But generally, that's what the entire MENA region is. Phoenician
type people. I don't know. I just feel like if I'm doing
It's a nice place. Well, I thought like I thought Morocco as
far as African nations went was actually quite wealthy for a
while.
I don't know where it is now. I don't know what the politics
have been like like up after let's say like World War I. I don't
really know what the politics were like. I thought around that
time they were
up in the world. They're like good. A lot of those North African
countries were.
And then I do think around the time of the um
uh Pan-Arab nationalism, I think a lot of them took a turn. Probably
pushed, okay, I'll give you probably pushed.
I'm I'm sure some somebody in the chat, some leftist going to
be like, "The CIA did this and that and that." Okay, I get
But still >> couple of shopping videos and my girlfriend
is too embarrassed to say that she's in a relationship with me
despite showing me publicly numerous times, then I would be pretty
about that. So, uh hey, Iman, if this Tik Tok you made is talking
about a real
Maybe not a casting agency if it's this
I lean back towards probably a boyfriend. Probably a boyfriend.
Maybe a good friend. I just to me it's like, dude, if that guy's
That guy has to be single to be spending that much time with
you
if he's straight or gay. I don't I don't necessarily disagree
with the analysis. I just disagree with getting like angry about
it. >> relationship where some guy didn't propose to you
after 2 years, then the way you treat Wait, I I agreed with the
Lily part, right? I was like, dude, if you're hanging out with
this guy all the time
he's attractive, he makes money, he has similar interests, and
you like hanging out. That's like everything. What What's the
problem?
And if he has a girlfriend, I feel like I feel like you're not
going to the gym
how would you say? You're not going to the gym constantly with
like an attractive person of the opposite right?
If you're both in relationships
probably or sorry, if one of you is in a relationship and the
other isn't. >> man might be the reason why a guy that
you want won't marry you. And also, vague posting about your
past relationships like this to publicly shame your ex is really
just a trashy move. Even if nobody in public knows who you're
talking about, everyone who knows you personally will. So, I
think her not being married despite her saying that she wants
to be might have a lot more to do with that than it just never
being the right time because of her career.
Uh totally defended Tectone for doing it, by the way. 100% defended
Tectone the whole time. >> Again, welcome to 30. I feel
like 10, 15 years ago, if you were a girl gaming online To What
are you What are you going to get mad about here? >> so
nice to you. Like so nice. They treated you so well. Oh, uh you
just like simps who gift you That's what's going to be >> you
free stuff, all this stuff. Do you guys remember? Sometimes I
think about these days and I'm like I I'm He just thinks that
men are there to give her money and attention, and that's it.
And she doesn't care about them at all. No wonder she can't get
married. >> hallucinating that, right? Maybe? Maybe? Yeah,
that happens when you base your career on your looks and you
start getting older. People pay less attention to you and give
you less money to be their parasocial girlfriend. Though, I will
say, just to be fair, just as much as there is girl
She's talking about people being nice on Runescape.
Do you think she was camming up with people on Runescape? Do
you think she was By the way, do you think she was 20 when she
was playing Runescape? or cope for missing milestones or for
acting like a loser, there's also guy cope for it. I've seen
a few videos talking about the chosen ones are unemployed right
now because our level of consciousness simply won't allow us
to choose a job that is not something that we actually prefer.
We're only going to choose something that we actually prefer
to do. And I would agree with this because I haven't had a job
in about 3 years. Wow. Right, this is exactly what someone who
is unhirable would say. Good, the comments are roasting him.
My faith in humanity has been slightly restored. Unemployed people
who are chosen for success don't make Instagram videos. They
work on themselves for 8 to 12 hours a day for free until someone
is willing to pay them for what they do. But if you are behind
or you're in like your late 20s and not much has happened, understand
that most people kind of slack off after they get what they want.
So, if you feel behind, note that you can catch up, and the way
that you do that is by simply Googling and researching faster
ways to do what you want to do so you can make up for the time
that you wasted by being able to do things like five times faster
than most people. Then you can take what you've already learned
from old skills and apply it to new ones. It is an
important to draw wisdom
That's like actually not the worst advice in the world right
there. That like you're probably never just totally far gone
because essentially people are always figuring out different
ways to get your done. You'll be able to catch up. Catching up
on knowledge is way easier than figuring stuff out and pushing
like the boundaries or
Just Google how to do things five times faster to catch up. Well,
no, the thing is is like basically, if you say what's the best
way to do X. Like if I go, "What's the best way to build a website?"
I'm going to get hopefully something that's relatively recent
that shows me a good way to do it. But if I if I looked at knowledge
from like 15 years ago and somebody started building websites,
they'll have some like stuff that carries along, but a lot of
that is just keeping up to date on your skills, right? I mean,
it's just surface level It is the exact kind of surface level
red pill that everybody Some people need to hear, and if it you're
hearing it from this guy for the first time, okay, you're hearing
it from this guy for the first time, you'll think, "Oh my god,
this guy changed my life." or some
Yeah, this is what Jordan Peterson hit you with. Actually, you
should clean your room. Maybe your parents weren't so wrong after
all. And everybody's like, "Oh my god, I do need it. I needed
to hear that from somebody who didn't hit me when I was a kid."
time that you wasted by being able to do things like five times
faster than most people. Then you can take what you've already
learned from old skills and apply it to new ones. It is important
to draw wisdom from many different places. If you take it from
only one place it becomes rigid and stale. Understanding others,
the other elements
and the other nations will help you become whole. Like I said
with the Forrest Gump stuff, there's a real value in being teachable
or in sports, they say people are coachable or not coachable.
The best players are the ones who listen to the people who are
better than them.
You'll be way further ahead if you just
The coachable thing is always like immediately red flag. Coachable?
Coachable? Pokimane, why aren't you
That's why we don't like Pokimane. She's not coachable, okay?
>> to people who have more life experience you're instead
of trying to find a 100% unique and creative answer to everything,
there's a time and a place to be creative, and it's not all of
the time. Typically, it's best to learn all the rules first before
you try to create new ones. Anyway, thanks for watching. Follow
me on Twitter, and I'll see you in the next video. Wow.
cool, dude. So cool.